[Music]
[Applause]
We Make Way for Daniel popper he covers
the Chargers for the athletic senior
writer for the athletic
let's I guess build up to what happened
over the weekend there Daniel Brandon
Staley's place here rumors uh Sean
Payton all of that how much of that was
on the front burner do you think going
into this game
yeah I don't know so much
Sean Payton I think heading into the
game what was really at the Forefront
was the Mike Williams situation
um where Brandon Philly makes the
decision to play his starters in that
week 18 game a meaningless week 18 game
he does it because he wants to maintain
momentum maina you know maintain a
rhythm which is something a lot of
coaches have done uh Mike Williams
suffers a fractured back in that game
and they are missing one of their most
important pieces he says Mike's going to
return to practice doesn't return to
practice he says Mike is going to travel
he doesn't end up traveling
um and they miss him in that game and
that was really at the Forefront and a
lot of people questioning why he played
his starters in that game but I think
the organization was aligned in that
decision so I don't internally I don't
think any of that noise was getting
through I don't think there was ever a
consideration for Sean Payton
considering you know how much he's going
to cost in terms of draft compensation
in terms of the contract itself
um but losing Mike Williams I think that
was hovering over the organization more
than anything else heading into this
game
what were you thinking at halftime
I'll tell you what I left to go grab a
soda and I walked past Eugene fernet of
the Florida Times Union and I told him
this game is going to be close
that's what I said because I felt it and
I've covered this team for Four Seasons
and you just know after that fumble
towards the end of the half
they punted away the Jaguars scored a
touchdown you can just feel it and you
just know with this organization it's
what I wrote about after the game you
just know that inevitably it's going to
happen and you felt the crowd just get
back into it a little bit just enough
right to make you feel like okay they've
got a chance and that place was loud and
it was rocking and you felt just enough
of an energy there at the end of the
half where I felt like hey I knew it was
going to be close it was inevitable why
is it when we look at the Falcons
melting down to Tom Brady in the Super
Bowl 28-3 it's on Matt Ryan not Kyle
Shanahan but what happened against the
Chargers against Jacksonville is not
unjust in Lawrence or Justin uh Herbert
it's gonna be on Brandon Staley
well I think that depends on how you
frame it you know the way I look at it
everyone's at fault Justin Herbert
missed a throw to Keenan Allen in the
first half he was wide open in the end
zone if they score that touchdown they
go up 31-0 and the game's probably over
instead they kick a field goal and it's
27 and nothing he missed a screen pass
throw he had three passes bad at the
line he missed a touchdown past the key
and Allen that went off a player's
helmet inside the five yard line so I
put on everybody they couldn't run the
ball Justin Herbert didn't play well
enough in the second half the defense
completely melted down like when you
when you blow a 27 and nothing lead you
can't just pin it on one person I know
in the media we love to find one reason
for why things go wrong but that's just
not the case particularly in football
it's always a lot of different things
and in this case it was everybody
Brandon Staley have an exit interview
this week as far as exit of the season
is that coming up
yeah yeah yeah they'll have discussions
here uh you know yesterday today they'll
have conversations you know over the
next couple days
um as an organization to figure out what
the what the best way to move forward is
because like in reality when you blow a
lead like that even though you made the
playoffs for the first time since 2018
even though you're improving you know
something has to change after you have a
debacle like that
but let's factor in ownership here
uh how different are they from other
ownerships around the NFL in in making a
move like this or not making a move
yeah you know they tend to stick with
coaches
longer than most owners you know there
are a lot of owners out there who will
make snap decisions who have knee-jerk
reactions especially after something
like this who will fire Frank Reich and
name Jeff Saturday head coach a guy
who's you know never been on a sideline
as a head coach in his career you know
there are owners out there who will do
that I don't think the spanos's are
those type of owners they like to see
things through they like to give their
coaches a full opportunity to in Anthony
Lynn's case turn things around and
Brandon's Daily's case to keep things
building and I think like in this case
they are building to something and I
know this this feels like a huge step
back because you blow a 27 to nothing
lead on National Television but talking
to these players over the last couple
days they feel like they are building
something here and they feel like if you
move on from Brandon Staley and
especially defensively you have to start
over from step one like that is a
daunting task for these guys because
they just felt like over this down the
stretch of this season that they had
started to really come into their own in
this scheme figure out their roles in
this scheme and start to play
defensively the way that they felt like
they were capable of and they don't want
to have to do that reset and then you
know cultivate those relationships over
again
Joey bosa's role in all of this uh
did you talk to him after the game
yeah I talked to him after the game he
said he's going to have a lot to say at
some point but he doesn't want to get
fined anymore than he's already been
fined
um I said okay and I went and moved on
to somebody else to talk to because you
only get so much time in the locker room
listen that was the first time I have
seen Joey Bosa really react in that
manner in my four years covering him and
he is has a very firm understanding of
the rules and how the game should be
officiated and if he is reacting like
that I get a sense that there was
something happening over the course of
the game where he felt like he wasn't
getting calls whether it's holding
you know whether it's illegal hands to
the face whatever he felt like should
have been called he didn't and I felt
like the first penalty led to the second
penalty because the first penalty felt
he got hold held he went and yelled at
the referee he said something to the
referee that forced him to throw the
flag they got into a little bit of a
spat and then from that point on you're
not going to get a call
like you're relying on the referee to
make a holding call because it happens
on every single play in the NFL and
um but then you can't react like that
you know two-point conversion you smash
your helmet in the ground you couldn't
wait to go another step because as soon
as you got in the sideline it's not a
penalty but you do it on the field it's
a penalty and that moves the two-point
conversion from two yards to one yard
and and that was a huge difference in
the game and and he took responsibility
for it yesterday who's the head coach of
the Chargers next year Brandon Staley
yeah I think he he's in my opinion he's
earned another season I think the
organization feels like he's earned
another season
um he's young and he's inexperienced and
they knew that when they hired him they
knew that he had been coaching in
division three
in that point five years ago at this
point six years ago there's going to be
a learning process for him in terms of
how he wants to go about things and he's
going to make mistakes like
being way too optimistic in the public
sphere when he's talking about Mike
Williams all week
um like you know altering his fourth
down decision making from one season to
the next season but the things that are
important he is very good at and I think
the hardest part about being a head
coach in the NFL is developing
relationships with players earning their
trust and cultivating a sustainable
culture and I feel like Brandon Staley
has achieved those things he has
improved from first his first season to
his next season and I feel like the
organization thinks that he's building
towards something despite this step back
and I really feel like Brandon still is
going to be the head coach now the rest
of the coaching staff will see but I
feel like Brandon Staley will be the
head coach of the Chargers next season
Daniel thanks for joining us we
appreciate it thanks for having me Dan
it's uh Daniel popper senior writer for
the athletic covering the Chargers